[Musik]
die konstruktion für das nächste
schießen 2020 hier zum bewegungs platz
einstieg simuliert einwohners
luftfahrzeuge dazu jetzt einen großen
großen strom gerade in konstruktion und
rüstung und wer technisch entwickelt
wurde sieht sich im wesentlichen aus
drei elementen zusammen der basis
bestehen dass hauptträger 3 kg drücker
und einer darauf montierten welle
darauf befindet sich drehbar gelagert
ein 15 meter langes rohr war auf diesem
aufgesetzt ein vier meter langes
kantholz auf dem sich die angesprochene
groß kochplatte befindet der vorteil
dieser konstruktion liegt in seiner
einfachheit und den raschen wechsel der
beschlossenen herdplatten dazu wird das
rohr im waagerechte position geneigt die
abgeschossene herdplatte mit sensen
kantholz ausgebaut
keine neuen herdplatte eingesetzt der
stromquelle verbunden in weiterer folge
wird der mast wieder in not rechte
position gebracht die herdplatte
entwickelt seine temperatur in weiterer
folge ist das team bekämpfen